hey what's up guys my name is a cello
and let's talk about mops so last
episode we talked about entities and how
they sort of interact with that game and
what they are basically and today we're
actually going to take a look at mobs so
what are mobs mobs are basically like
what mobs like the word moms like mob
literally means like a group of
something but you know in games I guess
what a mob is is basically like like a
play or it's essentially it's like a
creature that moves or a creature even
you could just call it like that if you
guys play Minecraft for example that's
probably a a game where they've actually
you know been called mobs like the whole
time not only in development but
actually in the actual game um but yeah
so be a mob think of a mole but it's
like I don't know anything from like a
cap to like a player that's a mob um so
basically today we're just going to take
a look at what they are and really the
differences between an entity and a mob
so in other words you know a mob is
still going to be an entity obviously
because an entity is pretty much any
object on our actual screen except for
like the map so like tiles so yeah mob
is still an entity but you know we're
going to talk about really um what what
like what other features and more brings
to the table so in other words the
additional the additional but
characteristics of a mob so first of all
over here at net in our package Explorer
or sorry out navigator on our entity
follow which will right-click and create
a new class and first is going to put it
into its own package called mob and it's
literally going to be mob that's just
going to be out our mob class so you can
see now I've got a nice hierarchy going
on here in the navigator and over here
in our mob class first thing we need to
do is make sure that it actually extends
entity all right because it is an entity
and we sort of wanted to um you know to
inherit all these all these variables
that we've um created
we'll also make it abstract and that's
about it
so again abstract means it can't be you
know instantiated because what it needed
to be instantiated because in no case
will we actually be creating a new mob
class because again we're using mob as a
template for all of our actual mobs that
we create so how does a mob
you know differ from an entity now I'll
talk about is yesterday and not
yesterday today before talking about
this is day before and I mentioned that
entities don't necessarily have sprites
now mobs do have sprites alright so the
first thing when you do basically is say
that you know it's got a sprite object
we need to have a would it mean to have
a sprite object and I'll just make it
protected for now again look
visibility's you know you can change
them obviously so if I change this down
the line you know just don't worry about
it but it's not that important if I make
everything public the game will still
run exactly the same as it would it's
just for cloak it's good programming
practice to actually restrict some
variables because that sort of reduces
the margin for error
if you accidentally access the wrong
variable or in other words you know we
should be we like in other words in this
case it'll help us out having it
protected because basically that that
tells us that that this sprite variable
can only be used you know within the mob
class and all of its some of its
subclasses so comp used outside of the
mob class basically you can't be used
outside of the mob out of the mob some
out out of mobs okay so only mobs can
actually access the sprite all the
different mobs that we create in the
future because only only subclasses can
actually access this sprite variable so
the other thing is um
mobs also tend to have a direction so
protected in a dir sense of direction
will probably have it 0 for now 0 is
usually north you know one is east two
is south and three is west that's sort
of the way that it usually works more or
less that's how I've always been doing
it the other things I'm not going to get
too complicated into here right now but
the other thing is probably protected
bullying walking or moving and also that
equals false and the reason is the mobs
usually have an animation when they're
moving so you know we want to be able to
manage that here as well now as to
methods there is going to be a move
method I I literally just create that
right now to public avoid move in fact
no I might actually keep it as public
not projected um explain why no reason
I'm actually get to it I'm not actually
gonna put in any parameters in to adjust
yet I will modify that move method in
the future but I'm just you know sort of
doing an outline for you guys
ah the other thing is public avoid
update obviously because mobs need to be
able to be updated so in other words
their location their position all that
stuff needs to get updated and you know
we have other things like collision
which um we could deal we're going to
deal with right now but so I'll just
simply put as prior bullying collision
so in other words if there's collision
it will return true there's no collision
it'll return false and obviously you
know for now just to get rid of Sarah
would return false but yeah that's
basically the way that a mob works now
one thing I haven't factored into here
that probably will be in the final game
well Donuts there's obviously a lot of
things but I mean out of the technical
aspects probably lighting when I'm
actually managing lighting in here at
all but you know we'll probably move on
to that when um when the time comes so
yeah that is basically the mob class
pretty much all we need to get a mob
working again this movement will
actually actually have to fill it in
with something update method will stay
pretty much empty as it is now and all
these variables will give us the
everything when turnover I'm up so yeah
um I hope you enjoyed the episode of
game programming if you did guys please
hit like button and I will see you guys
next episode so yeah let guys
you